gop congressman and afghanistan war
veterans brian mast and jim banks
i was listening to that gentleman and
was shocked it was like i was sitting in
a boring seminar at stanford with
someone spouting things that were rather
bizarre one of my one of the remarkable
things i made a note of was his comment
that we're going to continue with
diplomacy now that's the shift but we've
all run over to qatar right it's going
to be from doha
congressman mast your thoughts after
hearing that tonight yeah number one
what you said they're going to continue
diplomacy
uh when they couldn't even conduct
diplomacy when they had military on the
ground that's number one number two
probably the most dire thing that i
heard him say was this that the taliban
made a commitment to not allow
afghanistan to become a terrorist safe
haven let's break that down the
terrorists said they won't allow
that country to become a terrorist safe
haven that's
makes you wonder about blinking our
state department biden at at every
possible level yeah it is just stunning
i'm trying to think of all i made so
many notes of what we're do what we're
dealing with here because i mean we've
got um
such a shocking development in general
that this is seemingly over and yet
there are i think untold numbers uh uh
congressman banks about of how many
americans are still left and they it
suddenly it seems to be the incredibly
shrinking number and now it's at 100 but
they were had it had trouble giving us a
number early on and now it's this
magical number of people who somehow
just want to stay what are your thoughts
upon what you've just heard
well you heard him say that it's around
200 but closer to a hundred an hour or
so ago the state department said 250 and
then you have general mckenzie just said
just moments ago that it's in the few
hundreds of americans who are still left
behind enemy lines the fact of the
matter is they don't know they don't
know how many americans that they've
left behind and and the for and
furthermore it's unfathomable to me that
we would leave any american behind we
these guys decided that they would bow
down to the taliban and abide by the
taliban's deadline and their red lines i
i never in my life thought i would see
an american president kowtow to a
terrorist group like the taliban but
that's exactly what joe biden and his
team have done and at this point since
the last evacuation the last plane has
left
you now know the american people now
know that this president has done
something that no president american
history has done before he left
americans behind it's a it's a it's
disgraceful and he should be held
accountable for it
representative mass we heard a jackie
heinrich uh report earlier that the last
five transports did not include any
americans we know from rescuers we've
got incredible groups of americans
rescuing you know on on these kind of uh
random kind of flights of things that
they've arranged you know privately to
rescue people uh is is this a dynamic
that we can even comprehend here that
private americans including this network
uh rescuing over two dozen people who
had worked with us and their families
out of afghanistan how does our
government do that how do they not even
try to make this work where you've got
private citizens making it work in the
meantime
i think you actually touched on the one
silver lining the one the one bright
spot in the midst of all of this horror
is there still a few americans over
there that are showing the world who
america is just like those marines that
gave their lives americans that are
stepping up in and out of uniform to say
you know what there's a line that we're
not going to let you pass there's a
point that you will not go beyond that's
what those americans are going out there
saying they're showing the world these
are the lions that americans really are
don't look at this this lamb that's
standing in front of us president biden
this is the real america not not the
land that's holding up the white flag of
surrender to move out of bagram to move
out of the embassy to move out of the
country on the timeline of the
terrorists that's that's the only
bright spot that i can point to in the
midst of that it is a reminder gentlemen
of who we are what we stand for what we
are willing to accomplish ranging from
an instagram celebrity to a television
network to other retired military
everyone working to try to make this
right gentlemen you've both made a
personal a sacrifice in this war thank
you for joining me tonight i appreciate
it hey sean hannity here hey click here
to subscribe to fox news youtube page
and catch our hottest interviews and
most compelling analysis you will not
get it anywhere else